Alarms go off all around the facility.
Things descended into chaos so quickly.
Of course, the staff of the SCP Foundation
are extremely familiar with the horrors of
a containment breach by now, but this was
something exceptional.
Two anomalies had joined forces in an unexpected
fashion, neutralizing some of the weaknesses
that the two of them usually experienced.
Needless to say, this was bad.
More specifically, 74 dead staff members were
dead already.
Several different Mobile Task Forces had already
been dispatched to hunt down this terrifying
new anomaly, but none of them knew where it
was hiding in the depths of the site.
Little did they know, this deadly new hybrid
had already escaped the SCP Foundation, and
was on its way towards a nearby population
center.
That’s where the real fun would start.
But before we get to all that carnage, let’s
rewind the clock a little and find out how
this disaster started...
Some things just go great together: Like peanut
butter and jelly, milk and cereal, or clicking
“Subscribe” while you’re watching a
video by SCP Explained.
But for every match made in Heaven, there’s
also a match made in Hell.
Like being covered in sugar water while you
walk past a wasp nest, or doing tricks with
your awesome zippo lighter next to the gas
pump, or most horrifying of them all, a combination
of SCP-106 and SCP-035.
Of course, the reputations of these two horrible
creatures are well known and well feared enough
on their own.
SCP-106 is a humanoid abomination also known
as the Old Man, capable of walking through
walls and entering his own private pocket
dimension, where he practices his predilection
for pain to its full potential.
And then there’s SCP-035, also known as
the Possessive Mask.
This is one of the most powerful and dangerous
psychic entities that the SCP Foundation has
in its vast collection.
Some of its more minor unpleasant qualities
are things like the fact it constantly drips
corrosive black slime, or the fact it immediately
reduces you to a state of brain death when
you’re foolish enough to wear it.
On the more severe end of its abilities is
its power to crawl into the mind of anyone
around it, slowly whispering horrors into
their mind until they’re completely under
its control, or utterly broken.
It likely has designs on world domination,
or at the very least, to plunge the human
race into an unimaginable pit of eternal suffering.
The one saving grace is the fact that 035’s
corrosive slime slowly destroys the body of
its hosts, limiting the purview of each one
of its reigns of terror.
But occasionally, there are wonderful, terrible
exceptions to the rule...
Speaking of terrible, our story began, chronologically,
with SCP-106 showing one of its rare signs
of activity.
This, naturally, caused waves of panic to
rock through the researchers and security
staff of the site.
They’d need to grab a D-Class then plug
in and warm up the femur breaker.
They’d also need to mobilize groups of on-site
guards with powerful flashlights to slow the
gnarled old monster down.
But by now, SCP-106 had gotten wise to the
Foundation’s techniques.
He wouldn’t make himself so easy to capture
this time.
He wanted to have the proper time to enjoy
himself.
SCP-106 got up and phased through the nearby
wall.
His cell was never easy to escape - They filled
it with strange shapes and running water,
just to confuse his wretched old mind.
But once he was out, he was out.
He avoided the hallways, instead just phasing
from wall to wall until he reached a different
block of containment chambers.
That’s where the fateful meeting would take
place.
It wouldn’t be the first time he’d wandered
into other containment cells - his battle
with SCP-682 perhaps being the most famous
- but this time, something was different.
The room he’d just phased into didn’t
contain some huge, writhing monster, or another
humanoid beast.
It contained instead a glass container on
top of a podium, the walls coated in deadly
Telekill alloy to keep its prisoner’s immense
psychic power sealed in.
But now that SCP-106 was in the room, standing
mere feet away from the grinning, white mask
inside the glass container, there was nothing
keeping the two from having an extremely fateful
conversation.
The first thing SCP-106 noticed was the black
liquid leaking from the mask.
Strange.
It seemed to perfectly match his own secretions...
“Hello there, good sir!
It isn’t often I have visitors in here,
and even less so visitors who are as handsome
as you,” The Mask said, speaking directly
into the old man’s frail, fractured mind.
“I don’t believe we’ve ever been acquainted.
Come a little closer and remove the glass
box.
I’ll be able to hear you better that way.
Come on, come on, don’t be shy!”
The Old Man felt something about the Mask
was distasteful.
Even to a creature as despicable as SCP-106,
something about the Mask just seemed slimy,
metaphorically as well as literally.
And yet, it found itself stepping forward
towards the glass case, almost as though he
was sleep walking.
How was the Mask invading his mind like this?
He’d always been one of the more mysterious
creatures in the Foundation’s containment,
and yet, SCP-035 had slipped into his mind
like a warm bath.
On some level, it frightened him.
“Yes, yes, that’s wonderful!
Come closer, dear boy, you’re doing so well,”
The Mask said as the Old Man reached forward
and began lifting off the glass case.
“I think I’d look rather good on you,
don’t you agree?
Let’s cover up that nasty old face of yours.
You’ll look positively spiffing, old chap.
Just do exactly as I say, and this is all
going to go wonderfully.”
The Old Man picked up the Mask, somehow not
even in control of his own body anymore.
An almost electrical power seemed to pulse
out of the Mask and through the Old Man’s
rotting fingertips.
The Old Man was a sadist, but he’d never
before encountered this kind of utterly malicious
intelligence.
This was a mind geared to commit almost incalculable
evil, and while the Old Man was wondering
how exactly he felt about that, he was already
lifting the Mask up to his face, and watching
the universe go very, very dark.
Outside, a small army of Foundation security
operatives, armed with flashlights and assault
rifles, were charging through the halls, trying
to trace the movements of the Old Man for
recapture.
Back in the Old Man’s cell, a confused serial
arsonist was being shoved into the femur breaker
by a group of nervous and impatient researchers.
None of them knew they were dealing with an
entirely different beast down here now.
Eventually, the security team found the last
rusty scorch mark on the wall of a containment
cell...
Belonging to SCP-035.
Before they could even comprehend the terrifying
implications of this horrible scenario, they
charged into the cell in hopes of stopping
it.
But by the time they were in there, both the
Old Man and the Mask were already gone.
Well...
Not entirely.
Suddenly, the guards in the room felt an odd
sense of calm wash over them.
Not a true, authentic calm, but an artificially
induced one, like the lulling of cattle while
a bolt gun descends towards their foreheads.
The Mask’s psychic influence had pacified
them, making them perfect prey for the rotten
hands reaching out from the ground, and pulling
them down into oblivion.
The guards outside heard the most horrific
screaming.
They circled the door, terrified, aiming everything
they had at the entryway.
But it wouldn’t be enough.
Soon enough, this new hybrid beast - SCP-106
wearing SCP-035 - emerged, and began its onslaught.
It had the immense physical abilities of 106,
bolstered by 035’s diabolical intelligence
and ability to cloud the minds of its victims,
inhibiting their capacity to run away or fight
back.
But most frightening of all: Because SCP-106
was already adapted to resist the effect of
its own corrosive mucus, it was also perfectly
able to sustain the Mask as a host without
ever melting and falling apart.
See what we mean about a match made in hell?
“How do you like my new body, gentlemen?”
The Mask asked, its voice dripping with malicious
glee.
“It isn’t much to look at, I know, but
you’re about to get very well acquainted
with its collection of charming abilities...”
And the Mask stayed true to its word.
It rampaged through the containment site,
waltzing through walls like a gleeful schoolchild
with the heart and mind of the devil himself,
leaving a pile of melted, tortured corpses
in its wake.
Researchers, guards, janitorial staff.
Nobody was safe.
And with every killing, the rest of the staff
became increasingly afraid, only strengthening
the psychic hold of the Mask.
It was having the best day it could remember
in a long time.
The Site Director and his team put out a mayday
for all available Mobile Task Force units
to descend onto the area and help them deal
with this deadly new threat.
But by the time they were on their way, the
Mask and its new SCP-106 body had already
had its fun with the Foundation.
Even when they activated the femur breaker,
nothing happened.
The Mask was far more interested in the pain
it could cause outside, and far too intelligent
to be lured back into imprisonment by such
a simple trick.
Instead, the hybrid made its way out of the
nearby perimeter wall, finding its way to
a heavily armored Foundation ground vehicle
and sliding in through the door like a ghost.
The operative in the driver’s seat was immediately
terrified by the monster suddenly sitting
next to it, but then, the Mask’s psychic
effects took over his mind.
He became a calm, placid little servant, just
like all those other mortal fools.
“I feel like a change of scenery, old sport,”
the Mask said to him.
“Take me out to the nearest city, it can
be one of your choosing.
I feel like having a little night on the town.
It’s been far too long, you know...”
The hypnotized driver nodded and punched the
gas.
The guards were too busy controlling the aftermath
of the chaos within the site to even notice
the creature they were chasing had already
escaped.
And if it reached a nearby city, then the
chaos, cruelty, and madness it was liable
to release would be the biggest mess the Foundation
would need to clean up in quite some time.
Which was precisely what the malicious Mask
had in mind.
Meanwhile, Dr. Robert Scranton woke up in
a dark room.
Well, he wasn’t sure if it was a room, but
it was definitely dark.
He rose to his feet in this strange, black
void, surrounded on all sides by blackness.
It wasn’t the belly of SCP-3001 - the dreaded
Red Reality - again.
No, this was something new, and what’s more,
he had no idea how on Earth he’d gotten
here...
“Dr. Scranton!” said a cruel, mocking
voice behind him.
“Turn around, old chap.
It’s been far too long since I’ve seen
you in the flesh.
Well, in a manner of speaking, at least...”
Confused, Dr. Scranton turned and saw a vaguely
familiar sight - SCP-035, the Possessive Mask
- floating in the dark behind him.
What on Earth was happening here, he wondered?
“Oh, you really don’t remember, do you?”
The Mask said with a spiteful laugh, replying
to a thought he’d never voiced aloud.
“We’re in your mind, Doctor!
As it turns out, you’re harder to erase
than I thought, perhaps because you’re buried
so deep in the psyche of that monster.
No matter, I’ll get you eventually..”
How strange, Dr. Scranton thought.
This must be his mind playing tricks on him
somehow.
He raised a hand to scratch his head quizzically,
and only then realized that his right hand
was gone, simply vanished from the end of
his wrist.
The Mask gave another sick laugh.
“Ooh, it’s already started!
I told you I’d get you, Scranton,” The
Mask said.
“I never normally get to delete a mind slowly.
This will be amusing.”
“Where’s Anna?”
Scranton asked, suddenly wondering about the
safety of his beloved wife.
He couldn’t help but worry when this got
another cruel laugh out of the Mask.
“Don’t you remember, Robert?”
The Mask said, through giggles.
“You killed her.
You killed her with your toxic embrace.
She died terrified of you.”
And with that, all the awful memories came
flooding back...
Back in the real world, things weren’t any
less horrifying.
When the vehicle had finally made its way
to the nearest city, the Masked Old Man had
unceremoniously murdered its chauffeur and
decided to go for a little explore.
It’d been so long since it felt the sun
on its pristine white porcelain.
Such a beautiful day outside.
It couldn’t wait to kill some people around
here.
It began its rampage in a dark alley, snatching
some homeless people and unfortunate passers
by through the graffiti-stained stone walls.
By the time it was done with them, there weren’t
even any bones left.
But this would only be the start of the Masked
Old Man’s horrific rampage through the city.
Next, he invaded an office building and decided
to unleash his grisly wrath on the people
within.
Some were pulled through the ground while
chatting at the water cooler.
Others dragged through the walls as they went
to refresh their coffee.
Some were simply sitting at their desks, getting
on with their daily work, when a dark silhouette
appeared behind them.
Some turned around, saw the creature, and
screamed immediately.
Others remained in ignorance, and only screamed
when an acidic, rotting hand curled around
their shoulder.
But every single one of them screamed eventually.
By this point, the SCP Foundation had started
sending all the Mobile Task Forces in the
area to the nearby city after receiving reports
of unexplainable disappearances and murders.
Panic was starting to spread, and that panic
was only making the nightmarish psychic abilities
of the Mask even stronger.
The challenge would be intercepting SCP-106
and removing the Mask before it became too
powerful for them to do anything about it.
If they didn’t, they could be looking at
loss of life on a massive scale.
Which was exactly what SCP-035 hoped to indulge
in.
A young barista was having a stressful day
at a nearby boutique coffee shop.
She retired to the staff bathroom to splash
some water in her face and recenter herself.
She sighed and looked up from the sink into
the mirror to see if her makeup was running,
then screamed.
A dark figure was standing right behind her:
It looked like a rotting human corpse, dripping
with black slime, and wearing a grinning white
Ancient Greek comedy mask.
“I’m not interrupting anything, am I?”
The Masked Old Man said, amused.
Soon after, the dark presence had spilled
out into the coffee shop.
The psychic powers of the Mask caused its
victims to be paralyzed with sheer terror,
unable to escape its cruel hands.
The death toll of the day had already risen
to over a hundred, and the Masked Old Man
had no intention of stopping.
That’s when several police cruisers skidded
to a halt in front of the coffee shop.
Cops disembarked from their cars and pulled
their handguns.
“Step out of the store with your hands up!”
one of them yelled over a megaphone.
“Any sudden moves and we’ll blow you to
kingdom come!”
This made the Masked Old Man laugh.
Oh, how very adorable...
Not long after, he was driving a police cruiser
further into town, with a pile of dead cops
left in the street behind him.
This was shaping up to be such a wonderful
day.
He never wanted it to end.
Back in the pitch dark of the mindscape, Dr.
Robert Scranton was looking a little worse
for the wear.
Both of his legs had disappeared, along with
one of his eyes, and much of the rest of his
right arm.
His remaining eye was weeping, remembering
how his embrace, as the Old Man, had killed
his beloved Anna.
He’d lost his humanity and become the worst
kind of monster.
The kind who even hurts the people he loves
most.
SCP-035, floating in the darkness, was still
just laughing at him.
“You’re pathetic, Scranton,” it said.
“Look how little is left of you.
You haven’t even been human in decades!
Why not give up what little is left?
You’re mine now, and soon, you’re going
to be nothing at all.”
And Dr. Scranton kept crying, because he feared
the Mask was right.
Back in the city, the stolen police cruiser
pulled up in front of a preschool, and the
Masked Old Man got out.
This would be the perfect place for his next
little slice of fun.
Straightening himself up, he began walking
to the school, knowing that with the extent
of his psychic powers, nobody would be strong
enough to run away.
They’d all just have to sit there and suffer.
Just like Dr. Robert Scranton.
“Goodbye, Old Man,” The Mask said to him.
“I’m tired of talking to you now.”
Dr. Scranton was ready to give up and let
himself disappear.
But then...
Something occurred to him.
Knowledge from his Foundation days.
“I...
I must be wearing you,” Dr. Scranton said.
“I must be wearing you!”
Scranton reached up to his face with his remaining
hand, grasping at something.
Suddenly, the face of the floating Mask twisted
into an infuriated frown,
“What do you think you’re doing?”
It said.
“It’s too late, Robert.”
But Scranton wouldn’t be deterred.
He gripped something invisible over his face
and began to tug, even though pulling on this
invisible mask on his face was agonizing.
The whole void around him began to shake and
quiver, including the grimacing SCP-035.
Scranton just kept pulling.
“Stop that, you idiot!”
It roared.
“Stop it, stop it, stop it!
You’re going to ruin everything, you—“
But it was already too late.
Dr. Scranton murmured, “I’m sorry, Anna”,
and gave one last yank.
That’s when everything went white.
Back in the city, it thankfully wasn’t long
until a group of Mobile Task Force agents
was able to locate the two anomalies.
SCP-106 was sitting cross-legged on the grass
outside a pre-school - where, thankfully,
nobody had been hurt - and just staring off
into space.
In his trembling hands was another familiar
sight: a frowning SCP-035.
Now go check out “The Whole Story!
- What if SCP-096 Wore SCP-035?”
and “SCP-106 - The Old Man Origin Theories”
for more tales concerning today’s terrifying
anomalies!